a tres meses para el inicio de los
juegos olímpicos de tokio la situación
epidemiológica del país no es buena las
autoridades se han visto obligadas a
decretar un nuevo estado de emergencia
en la capital no el número de
infecciones en todo el país ha seguido
aumentando desde el mes pasado y el
sistema de atención médica de algunas
prefecturas se encuentra en una
situación difícil sin precedentes que
vigiló que un animal cuyo auto con base
en esta situación decidimos emitir el
estado de emergencia en tokio osaka
kioto y joey votto que tengo ideas magia
sin embargo esto no parece preocupar a
los organizadores que siguen defendiendo
una celebración de este evento bajo
estrictas normas sanitarias
tokio te esperamos que el gobierno
japonés ser de tokio y los gobiernos
locales mejoren la situación del cob y
19 estados y nosotros tomaremos
contramedidas aún más fuertes como
teorías de estas olimpiadas ya fueron
suspendidas en 2020 a causa de la
pandemia y un nuevo aplazamiento sería
desastroso para la organización pero no
todos comprenden esta decisión
en las calles de tokio reina el
escepticismo ante el miedo por el
aumento de contagios
con este estado de emergencia creo que
sería muy difícil celebrar los juegos
olímpicos muchos se verán afectados y
los puntajes suben y no creo que
necesitemos ahora los juegos olímpicos
a pesar de que las olimpiadas de tokio
son un evento clave para japón la
vacunación apenas ha avanzado el país
comenzó a inocular dosis a mediados de
febrero pero solamente algo más del 1
por ciento de los ciudadanos han sido
inmunizados debido a que únicamente se
ha autorizado la vacuna de facer y hay
cierta reticencia en la población